(gentle music)
- A lot of my clients
and their family members
live in a constant state of fear.
Thirty years ago, I mean,
there were very little deportation cases,
and now that is the bulk
of cases that we take.
Many of the cases go through
the Stewart Detention Center,
and a lot of attorneys
don't take Stewart cases.
I really worry that,
if I were not in some of my client's lies,
that they would be in a
very difficult situation.
I do what I do because I am an immigrant.
I know how they feel;
I know what their family
members are going through.
I would hate for someone
not to have the proper representation
because I know that I'm
really their last hope.
I was born in the Dominican
Republic and, at 12 years old,
my family and I moved
to the United States.
We moved to New York, and
then we moved to Georgia.
I went on to Georgia State University,
and then I got a chance to work
at an immigration law
firm as a receptionist,
and it was really a blessing
because my uncle was picked up by ICE.
You know, we never thought
that that would be possible
because we came here with a green card.
Why is ICE picking my uncle up?
Why is he at Stewart Detention Center
when he's not here illegally?
He was detained for almost a year
until we were finally able
to win the removal case,
and it was at that moment I knew
that I wanted to become
an immigration attorney.
(somber music)
So, how are you?
- I'm scared, I'm really scared.
I'm not gonna lie.
I'm scared to be in this place,
and I'm scared to go back to my country.
Honduras is not a place where
you can live freely, you know?
Not if you're gay and I know for sure
that if I appeal again,
they will take longer as well, you know?
- Yeah.
- And it's probably
gonna be another year.
- Yeah, no, I understand.
I mean this is a very serious,
serious decision that you have to make.
- Yes.
- Of course, as a lawyer,
I always want to keep fighting.
- Yes.
- We never really give up--
- Right.
- But it is at the expense
of your freedom.
- I would like to say that
I would like to fight,
because I know that you have
done everything that's possible
and, like I told you before, I'm so grateful
to have you as my lawyer.
- We do a lot of these cases pro bono,
and we have 1,500 active cases.
The majority of my clients
have lived here for decades.
They have built a life here.
They pay taxes; they have children here;
and they have lived crime-free lives,
and then they get pulled
over for traffic violations.
And you know, that's how they
end up in ICE detention.
So in order for me to
visit a client at Stewart,
normally, I have to get up at 4:00 a.m.
It's far away.
It takes us about three
hours, one-way, to get there;
and for years, Stewart had
the highest deportation rate
in the country.
It's in the middle of
nowhere, cold and isolated,
and just very difficult to get access to.
It's difficult to get
access to the clients.
It's difficult for media to get access.
It has a horrible reputation.
I hear from my clients all the
time about the mistreatment.
These individuals deserve
that their cases be heard
before a judge, so I
have to fight for them,
and I have to give them
their day in court,
and they're grateful for
that, that's what they want.
I've had many cases
where my clients come in
and they said, "I've
met with five attorneys
"and they told me that
nothing could be done,"
and we have been able to win their case.
That's really why I do what I do,
why I don't take no for an answer.
If a client is willing to
allow me to fight their case,
I will fight the case till the end.
(speaks in foreign language)
- You know, I really wish
that the immigration debate
could be more focused
on the actual people.
I mean, I represent
surgeons, nurses, teachers
who are just here trying to
provide for a better life.
It's really a privilege,
and it's really a blessing
to do what I do.
I get strength from the cases
that we are able to win.
It definitely brings great joy to my life
'cause I know I've made a difference.